[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu sou uma mulher trans eu pra quem não
conhece o termo trans pode ser uma
obrigação um sinônimo de transexual é
transexual é um conceito tá mais popular
mais acessível na mídia mas hoje a gente
reconhece que o termo politicamente
correto né seria transgénero porque a
gente entende que o gênero é muito maior
do que o sexo biológico para quem não
está familiarizado com o conceito
basicamente uma pessoa trans é aquela
pessoa que nasce com de ter ficado com
um determinado gênero nascer mas ela a
sua identidade é do gênero oposto
então por exemplo é eu eu nasci um
menino mas a identidade de gênero é de
uma mulher assim como existem mulheres
trans existe também um homem transmite
no caso oposto na criança identificada
como menina ao nascer mas ao longo da
vida lá se descobre com a identidade de
gênero masculina o oposto de trans é a
pessoa se ela basicamente ela se
identifica com aquele gênero que ela
nasceu ela não tem um desligamento da
sua identidade
dito isso essa pequena introdução sobre
o que é uma pessoa trans
eu queria convidar vocês a fazer uma
reflexão a partir do momento que uma
pessoa chega pra você fala assim eu sou
transou se lê uma notícia só uma pessoa
sttrans em algum lugar qualquer é a
primeira imagem que vem à cabeça de
vocês
dando o meu exemplo de contar um pouco
da minha história eu sou uma pessoa que
eu sou consultor de tecnologia
eu trabalho com desenvolvimento de
software eu também sou palestrante na
área de tecnologia eu tenho circulado em
praticamente o várias cidades do brasil
e mais recentemente feito até palestras
internacionais ou seja me considero uma
pessoa relativamente bem-sucedida e só
pra não ficar falando só de trabalho
também gosta de correr eu sou o meia
maratona está sim eu gosto de correr 21
quilômetros
o meu sonho é algum dia poder correr a
maratona e
podemos falar mas há também os que são
mais bonito mas infelizmente não é essa
a imagem que a gente tem
nekounan discuta uma a essa frase a uma
pessoa trans porque o nosso consciente
coletivo é construído o conceito da
tantas pessoas trans é construído a
partir daquela base de conhecimentos que
vem basicamente de páginas dos jornais
que geralmente estão na seção policial e
com isso a gente tem aquela sensação de
que pessoas transitam de uma relação
muito forte com a prostituição com
criminalidade com promiscuidade com
drogas com uma série de problemas
sociais inclusive e enfim é essa
construção ela acaba gerando esse
preconceito
e olha só como é esse problema é um
problema grave porque o preconceito ele
acaba gerando o próprio preconceito a
pessoa a pessoa quando ela vai se
assumir trans ela muitas vezes se
encontra com uma barreira que as pessoas
não querem ser associados com aquele
conto com todo aquele contexto e elas
simplesmente fecham as portas vai fechar
a porta a família fez porta os amigos o
abandonam oportunidades de empregos
homem e o que acontece é por incrível
que pareça seja um conceito
revolucionário pessoas trans são pessoas
e a gente precisa comédia precisa pagar
o boleto ele tem contas a pagar e enfim
a gente precisa ganhar dinheiro e quando
essas pessoas não tenham oportunidades o
que acontece
ela se vê em uma situação desesperada e
eventualmente ela tem duas escolhas uma
delas é reforçar o estereótipo aquele
estereótipo do preconceito é porque elas
precisam ganhar dinheiro ou ainda uma
solução mais trágica é um suicídio e não
existe até talvez população com a taxa
de suicídio tão alta quanto a população
trans que dependendo do estudo que vocês
forem a observar varia de 30 a 50
o centro é um número muito alto então
quando falo aqui de privilégio de estar
aqui de falando com vocês já têm um já
me sinto muito privilegiada por ser uma
do grupo que sobreviveu e mais do que
isso eu ainda sou uma das pessoas que
não precisou se prostituir se 10% das
pessoas trans não precisarão se
prostituir
isso é um privilégio muito grande só que
não quer dizer que esse preconceito não
me afetou
é claro só alguns preconceitos no meu
dia a dia
mas pior do que esse foi o preconceito
que eu aprendi a ter comigo mesma
durante o desenvolvimento
quando a gente é criança na memória mais
antiga de eu ser uma pessoa transita
pessoa diferente é mais ou menos umas
quatro cinco anos de idade
eu lembro de parecer que havia uma
parede invisível entre eu e aquele grupo
que eu queria fazer parte do grupo das
meninas porque quando a gente é criança
a gente tem a designação de um gênero ea
gente sabe todo um formato do que aquele
gênio representante recebe um
treinamento a se comportar como aquele
gênero
então eu nasci o menino então tinha um
nome masculino tinha um corte de cabelo
um tipo de roupa que tinha usar a minha
cor favorita era uma paleta específica
que eu podia escolher sobre as
brincadeiras brinquedos as pessoas que
interagir tudo isso era padronizada e
qualquer comportamento diferente de si
era reprimido entendia que era sujo que
era feio ser daquele jeito mas claro nem
tudo era ruim é eventualmente você
aprende algumas coisas do universo
masculino que são tidas como tipicamente
masculina eu acabei absorvendo por
exemplo ao gostava gostava de jogos que
estava de videogame saúde coisas que
eram reconhecidos com masculinas
ok vida segue e chega à puberdade e ali
na verdade o conflito não era mais sobre
a diferença e masculino e feminino
eu tinha transformações físicas
acontecendo no meu corpo
hormônios agindo ea cada dia que passava
era terrível porque parava de me
reconhecer em um espelho
eu chegava gente que está acontecendo
comigo
só que assim com a puberdade vem também
o interesse
romântico sexual enfim eu me interessava
por meninas e isso era o avião havia um
outro preconceito meu quero é o seguinte
vá eu aprendi que homens gostam de
mulheres e mulheres gostam de homens e
com imagine a confusão que se formou na
é na minha cabeça e o que aconteceu
então eventualmente entende que eu tinha
que reprimir aquilo por que aquilo era
feio aqui logo que eu tinha aprendido
era uma coisa feia então eu para me
esconder eu fui exatamente para o lado
oposto
eu procurei me esconder sendo a pessoa
ou o cara mais machão possível porque
era eu tinha na zona de conforto e aqui
ninguém vai perceber que eu tenho aqui o
lado feio
inclusive nessa época eu fiz muitas
coisas que eu não me orgulho eu
aproveito essa oportunidade que a gente
tem uma certa visibilidade eu quero
pedir desculpas às pessoas que eu acho
que naquela época se estiverem vivendo
por favor porque realmente naquela época
estava usando uma máscara para esconder
quem eu era e essa energia que eu
gastava para me esconder
começou a destruir eu entrei em
depressão eu perdi a vontade de viver
realmente e as coisas foram se agravando
mas eu tive a sorte de nascer na era da
internet e eu consegui através de
estudos eu queria entender o que estava
acontecendo comigo e chegou um momento
que eu finalmente encontrei o algumas
explicações eu finalmente entende que
uma coisa é a identidade de gênero que é
basicamente quem se identifica e outra
coisa é a orientação sexual que é de
quem você gosta e a partir do méxico
desconstruído tirei essa ligação eu
comecei a ver quanto outras coisas
estavam erradas quanto os outros
preconceitos eu havia aprendido que eu
precisava de fazer um outro deles foi o
fato que computação é uma coisa
masculina porque eu comprar o computador
não tem sexo porque o computador tem que
ser um conceito masculino e hoje a gente
já fala muito isso é o lugar da mulher é
onde ela quiser
então a santi isso outro preconceito que
enfrenta
tá eu comecei a organizar eu comecei a
entender como eu era e eu finalmente eu
cheguei à conclusão aqui eu não posso
mais viver essa vida desse jeito eu vou
realmente fazer o processo que ele chama
de transição que a mudar de um gênero
para o outro e isso envolve tratamento
hormonal psicólogos têm uma avaliação
psicológica bem extensa laudos enfim
cirurgias também foram algumas sugestões
necessárias e só que eu sabia que se eu
fizesse isso de uma forma desestruturada
ela ia cair aquele estereótipo que eu
descrevi no começo então também não
podia fazer de qualquer jeito tive que
me planejar muito nessa época eu
trabalhava numa multinacional americana
numa área de vendas vendas de tecnologia
e eu conversei com as pessoas
responsáveis é uma empresa que ela tinha
uma política de de não discriminação
eu pensei aqui estou protegido ok vamos
vamos em frente
e foi num belo dia tinha uma reunião de
equipe
no final dessa reunião eu seqüestrei
alguns minutinhos para falar de mim eu
cheguei pessoal então a situação é essa
de agora em diante eu só daniela isso
para mais ou menos umas 20 pessoas
aquela notícia correu que nem fogo na
empresa sentiu as pessoas gostam de
falar e aquele momento foi muito
interessante porque antes daquele
momento era uma pessoa muito bem
respeitada bem conhecida tecnicamente na
empresa ea partir daquela nenhum eu era
daniela transexual não era mais aquela
profissional super qualificado aqui as
pessoas vinham e falar o petro sa vem
aqui me dá uma opinião claro que
eventualmente isso culminou que as
minhas opiniões já não era mais tão
importantes
alguns anos depois eu fui demitida e eu
estava lá no mercado enfrentando uma
situação completamente nova que era
procurar emprego como mulher eu não
estava acostumado com isso não entende a
diferença
eu fiquei seis meses procurando mesmo
sendo extremamente mais qualificado
o que eu era quando eu era um homem e
claro eu conseguir realmente me colocar
no mercado hoje eu tenho uma posição
muito boa como eu falei me considero uma
pessoa bem sucedida mas eu só consegui
entrar porque eu tive indicação de uma
pessoa que me conheceu no mundo passado
né
isso foi uma coisa que para mim foi
bastante marcante eu acabei claro foi
superado hoje eu tô numa empresa muito
bacana eu tenho essa visibilidade como
palestrante é mas ainda por exemplo eu
não tenho a remuneração que tinha antes
esse gap de gênero na de pagamento de
porque existem diferenças eu sou hoje
uma pessoa mais velha mais madura mais
qualificado do que era antes e isso são
preconceitos que a gente tem na nossa
sociedade que a gente aprende a gente
coloca essas caixinhas e muitas vezes a
gente não se questiona eu tive digamos
um grande conflito interno que me forçou
a pensar sobre os meus preconceitos
só que não necessariamente todo mundo
tem esse estímulo mas há uma certa forma
eu sei que cada um de nós tem para sair
de casa veste máscaras de um maior maior
ou menor intensidade
e para sustentar suas marcas a gente
também gasta energia então a reflexão
que eu queria trazer para vocês hoje a
quanta energia vocês gastam para não
está sendo em quem vocês não são pra mim
eu sei que isso custou caro eu só
recuperei a minha saúde depois que eu
comecei a derrubar essas máscaras mas é
importante refletir que você não precisa
ser transparente um benefício disso e a
partir desse momento em que a gente
começa a refletir sobre os preconceitos
desconstruir eles a gente também está
criando basicamente um mundo melhor um
mundo mais diverso onde a gente consegue
valorizar também diversidade diversidade
com a diversidade cognitiva a
diversidade das idéias pode se expressar
melhor que o mundo literalmente mais
livre e juntos é possível é aprender a
aprender para a gente construir este
mundo que a gente gasta nossa energia
brow em coisas que nos faz feliz e assim
construir um mundo melhor
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]